the governor of georgia making a trip to
the southern border this week to check
in on his state's national guard troop
station there
and get a firsthand look at the growing
crisis this after calling out
vice president kamala harris for not yet
making a visit
to the u.s mexico border herself joining
me now
georgia's governor brian kemp governor
thank you for taking time
on saturday you just heard a democrat
border state congressman henry cuellar
saying that it's not under control
what did you see on your visit to the
border
well you know he and senator kelly both
got it right it's a crisis it's
unbelievable
what is happening there griff i was
there in december visiting our troops
before the christmas holidays and
much different right now you look at the
numbers in january they had 17
000 apprehensions in in mcallen in that
area they're patrolling
february went to 28 000 march it was 62
000. they're going to hit
60 again they're going to have 600
000 apprehensions just in this year at
mccallum so very
very much different than it was the
cartels are making a lot of money
shipping people across the border
they're
they're you know really have a strategic
plan they'll start throwing
kids and people in the river that can't
swim to divert
border patrol agents from getting this
these cartel members
and then we'll also send people across
to be a decoy
to draw attention to them and then send
you know float forward rangers
full of drugs across the river and get
them into the interior of the country
so really drastically different
versus december when i was there
governor you are
out on the rio grande on a riverboat
patrol there so you saw
just what you're talking about there and
i got a source in the rgv where you were
2245 apprehensions in the last 24 hours
if you could give just one piece of
advice to
the vice president who's spearheading
this and president biden
about what needs to be done based on
what you saw what would that be
well look the first thing i think they
should do is get on the ground there and
talk to the border patrol agents that
are doing this every day
talk to the texas troopers that i talked
to to the georgia national guardsmen
that are there
doing three different logistic missions
flying helicopters
to help spotting with border patrol
fleet maintenance and working in the
tactical op center
to run cameras that were mentioned
earlier and and really get an
understanding for what's going on i mean
they are being overwhelmed they need
some more people they need more
resources
you know i had the opportunity to bump
into governor abbott for just a few
minutes after being briefed by all of
his folks
i mean they are going to be spending a
fortune just the state of texas
is uh next year to help support a
federal mission of protecting the border
i mean it's really
uh terrible what's happening and these
kids you know to say the crisis is over
is not true they've moved these children
that were in
the cages that they you know cried about
months ago
and they're just moving them to
different parts of the country and i can
tell you that people on the ground there
are really worried that the title 42 if
that goes away it'll be worse than it is
now which is hard to believe i mean this
is the
the worst numbers ever uh since they've
been
yes keeping them on on people coming
across the border and the number of
apprehensions you mentioned tele42
that's the
health concern mechanism for which we do
deport people let me ask you
what you make of the fact that on the
day that you went to the border
president biden came to
georgia and was heckled by anti-ice
activists take a quick listen
to what he got treated to
[Music]
i agree with you i'm working on a man
give me another five days
agrees with him does that concern you
that the president's
really not getting the message from the
border agents you talked to
yeah i you know i heard a little bit of
that on the news coverage and i don't
quite understand that
obviously he doesn't understand what's
happening on the
border instead of coming to to georgia
he really should be going to mccallum
texas or arizona or some of these other
places
and really getting a handle on what's
going on in our country
and governor thank you for taking time
in just about 10 seconds we got left
you're intending to sign some bills
regarding
human trafficking yeah we've uh look our
first lady's doing as much as anybody in
the country to end human trafficking but
not only that grift also
also to support the victims of human
trafficking we had three additional
pieces of legislation again this year
unanimous support in our legislature so
we continue to move the needle on that
tragic issue
governor brian kemp thank you very much
for taking time have a great rest of
your saturday